i saw here that bill and melinda gates
are getting divorced
it's pretty wild but anyway um i wonder
what is alex jones uh
yes alex come on in infowars.com
howard the gates were so perfect
together
they were going to call 96 percent of
the population they ate children
together they stayed at jeffrey
epstein's paris and state 497 times
i can't i just can't believe it happened
wait a second alex
alex.com are you saying you're upset
about bill and melinda gates uh
uh divorcing i would have thought i'm so
upset that they can't continue the covet
19 crimson contagion battle plans to
control society and the fake pcr test
with klaus schwab's book the great reset
where they're going to push the
eugenicist d
population oh i'm so upset about that
i'm so happy
so you're you're being sarcastic in
other words you're happy you're
celebrating the end of billy melinda
gates
melinda gates is joining the fight for
freedom she has denounced the satanic
deep state overlord husband she's
abandoning the stockholm syndromes
listen it takes a bold person to stand
up to the leader of the interdimensional
vampires the
satanic globalist pedophile cults they
commit crimes against humanity to prove
their credit with the aliens
you're saying melinda gates was actually
suffering from stockholm syndrome and
she finally got away
from the evil warlord bill gates is that
correct
evil known villain
hold on one second howard i'm getting a
knock at my door let's see who is it
come
in it is i reptilian bachelor
bill gates oh my god bill gate
let me ask you something i really want
to have a serious interview gates
what was the breaking point in your
marriage with melinda
melinda always complained that i left
crumbs
after my baby feast you know it's going
to be hard for you to date
i mean when you're eliminating all of
humanity how are you even going to date
i will slaughter all of civilization
except kaya gerber she will be queen of
the
all right well enough out of you gates
well let me tell you something
if you need a quick meal in your new
bachelor pad
you need liberty food buckets this is
high performance powdered survival food
you got powdered lasagna powdered
burgers powdered chicken fingers
made with the finest ingredients loaded
with baby powder loaded with sawdust
this stuff's gonna fill you up good
40 off with promo code felon fouchy
infowars.com well
what infowars.com i'm i'm thinking about
it blowing my mind this was a show
within a show within a show
i have a show going on you came on with
your show and then you put on another
show with bill gates so this is
yeah he was knocking at our door and
then somebody knocked at his door
right wait i'm hearing imaginary knocks
on the door right now all right
let me ask you is it hard for you to
sleep at night with all you know
it must be hard for you to calm down
well it's not hard when you have
alpha male sleep fusion that you take
every night filled with vitamin x it's
very good for you so that's how i get to
bed
every night but listen i am up every
night when i don't take the fusion
because
i'm just imagining the satanists that
want to cut our arms and legs off and
how they're going to
externalize the nsa spy system into big
tech how come it's taking so long for
the globalists to
to you know get rid of the population
people are slowly getting the facts
they're understanding this
satanists take drugs because they want
to end
the veil they eat children for the
interdimensional pain
then the aliens hand over the inventions
that's how we got the wheel that's how
we got the television that's how we got
the iphone they
feed off dark energy right bill gates
all hail bill gates yes do you ever have
a margarita on the beach i mean don't
[ __ ] chill out i mean it's
to me it's just uh intense your world it
really is
listen i like a little good whiskey we
got some good whiskey here and austin
sit down have a little bit of bluebell
ice cream i love i love all of those
kind of things
the core goal is taking down the mega
banks
taking down the powerful elites taking
on the prime controllers taking down the
greys
you know i look at some people i look at
teddy roosevelt for example
that man the man's my hero he was an
elitist right but he wanted to empower
people
he made the great national parks he
pissed off the fed
want to break up the big banks and the
monopolies and that's the kind of man
that i look to
i aspire to not these chicken neck
perverts who want to sterilize the
population
and put the human brain at glory and the
cloning programs these globalist
democrat nazis all right all right
listen alex we gotta go because i have
my own commercials and own show to run i
can't run your show
products to push all right i gotta go
take a fish i'll be back right
after these words
you